das ist verboten heute
wir dürfen nicht lange wollen wir direkt
einfach ja machen kommt bloß nicht lache
mit dir es einfach nicht möglich ja und
ich habe die rosen mitgebracht
auf meinem hemd nicht das ist geil
lachend wegen es eigentlich nur darum
auch heute noch das was ich an dir mit
absoluter spitzenreiter zu machen ob das
heute bücher sind einfach ein grund du
zwischendurch immer passt offenbar
würden schwein gehört sein und ja lied
ist noch mal ein anderes also ist es
halt so eine hot dogs in einem zelt oder
so ist halt ganz nice warum haben wir
uns hier wieder getroffen um die nicht
nach anscheinend aufzunehmen ich bereue
es jetzt schon wieder das sie nach köln
gefahren bist
[Musik]
ich würde das bist du wenn du die
führerscheine kanadischen high und hoch
war schon jetzt kommt schnapp das model
habe
[Musik]
er denkt wie so was kannst du auch
das fenster schließen
[Musik]
ich wusste dass sowas kommt aber ich
habe es gehofft dass das so was das
kabel die vergessenen 50 klasse a team
ist mein licht bringen sie mir da was
vorbei alter sohn kommt leichter und
besser gewesen habe wissenschaftlich
bewiesen dass menschen mit einem höheren
iq deutlich
wer hochburgen ein lifestyle dass mein
bruder ja das ist leider wahr alter herr
genießt das haben wir nie
ich habe noch nie genießt logisch ich
muss derzeit 70.000 mal täglich polen
alter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ach so ich war nie weg der vater bei der
wahl hut das habe ich nicht gesagt
[Musik]
jetzt hatte ich schon so häufig ich habe
auch so oft einfach wollte ich so
trinken dann brandenburg alles klein war
noch besser als sein abitur aber diese
ganzen neuen schule die die leute da
draußen tragen von valencia und der ja
das sieht das sieht aus wie ein schuh
das sieht aus wie eine behinderung das
ticket nur ein dass wegen annas auf
pizza
ist das oft pizza ich finde es nicht so
schlimm aber du ist auch alles ne von
mama ist immer so gewesen immer der gute
alte msv-chef bushido ak inspektor
gadget sich doch gerade melo war und ich
muss sagen entstehen als erwartet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt das neue video von der leyen so
lange nicht angekommen
ein schutzgeld aufs letzte woche ist
noch nicht angekommen
es gibt keinen grund war nicht drin zu
sein es sei denn es zeigen
du bist blind taub an diesen gibt so wir
haben uns jetzt einen kebab zum
mittagessen genehmigt gezahlt wurde
natürlich getrennt und ja ich sage nur
bon appétit
[Gelächter]
was ist bei ihr denn falsch gelaufen
diesen
das ist kaufland immer solche anzüge an
diese auch kaufland einer tüte stimmt
das sind die dinge die du dann halt weiß
also ich habe wirklich geglaubt dass wir
freunde sind kumpels sind ja man ist so
ist dass diese alten freund das alles
bei stress mit der polizei nicht bleiben
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
auch die grenzen
aber ja
zudem
nein aber es hat mir vor ein paar folgen
schon das ist dieser cdu-abgeordnete was
hat der gemacht
mögen sie sich nicht da hat einfach
lustig geguckt erst ein video ist nicht
mehr lustig wenn man es erkläre hast du
kleiner entertainment riesen business
madame münchen langsam
[Musik]
sollen wir das hat jeder gesehen
hier bin ich mir da oftmals nicht sie
sich was denkst du was ich da jetzt
chance gesehen hätte ich nicht dass mein
humor ja man dachte erst das ist eine
richtige handeln dem richtigen
allerdings war das was es ist nicht
witzig wenn man es erklärt sandra
[Musik]
das verstehe ich nicht fähig die technik
bestand das ist auch geht eigentlich im
gaming oder denkst du dass wenn man in
technik gut ist dass er mit elf dass
meine menschen wieder belebt
der lukas erklärt besonders stinkt noch
ein bisschen mein gästebad ist denn ich
nehme kein statement jetzt dazu du
nimmst kein statement dazu lädt es ist
sagte herthas hier
ich habe mir übels auf die lippe
gebissen ja es gibt einen rat herpes ja
was dann zu ihren fähigkeiten ich bin
sehr zuverlässig und ich habe mit meinem
besten freund aufs netz statt 800
flammen sie sind eingestellt
so wird es bei dir dann ablaufen ich
will mich einfach nackt präsentieren wir
beenden sitzt hier meine lieben freunde
wenn euch die heutige folge nicht lachen
mitwanderer gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch und dem video am
morgen kommt eine neue podcast folge
raus einen link dazu findet ihr auch
unten in der infobox und mein instanz
dort verlinkt oder abonniert main kanal
und sandra hat die letzten sechs wörter
ich hasse luca war eher hässlich deutsch
war noch nie so dann gute nacht
deutschland